en fait j'étais pas d'accord avec lui
parce que je trouvais qu'il pouvait les
remettre pour son œuvre mais là prenez
la colère mais là où je comprends qu'il
soit mis en colère c'est que quand trois
fois il lui demande est-ce que tu peux
dire ce plateau que tu ne cautionnes pas
l'antisémitisme il tourne autour du pot
là je trouve que Gilles il tourne autour
du pot parce qu'il a pas envie d'obéir à
Gilles Verdez ouais mais non mais là
Jean-Marie comme pour parler comme toi
qu'est-ce que j'ai dit hier tu étais pas
là hier alors tu m'as entendu dire je
vais te dire ce que ce que
comment il s'appelle Francky devait dire
est-ce que tu voulais entendre je vais
te le dire moi et donc j'ai essayé et il
aurait dû faire ça ça aurait été éteint
le feu tout de suite on est d'accord
mais c'est pas une raison pour le
traiter trois quarts de de d'antisémite
quand même non mais sauf que quand tu
refuses de de condamner le télétisme au
bout d'un moment c'est un peu compliqué
et je comprends que ça allait énervé
c'est la question c'est pour ça que je
dis ça mais alors toi Guillaume non non
moi j'avais hier j'avais l'impression
d'être dans un tribunal et pas sur un
plateau de télé et en fait on a assisté
au procès de Francky Vincent qui parce
qu'il a eu le malheur de dire
pas rigoler une fois une vanne de
Dieudonné s'est fait taxer d'antisémite
non seulement c'est faux je suis désolé
c'est pas parce qu'on regarde un sketch
de données qu'on antisémite et en plus
c'est extrêmement dangereux parce que le
résultat de ça c'est quand une fois
encore une fois on monte les gens les
uns contre les autres ça crée de la
haine ça divise les gens et on a un mec
qui est venu en plateau pour nous parler
de sa légion d'honneur pour ses chansons
qui sont des chansons joviales et qui se
retrouvent là et qui ressort de là avec
une étiquette d'antisémites que tu lui
as collé Gilles et franchement c'est
dégueulasse et c'est dangereux de penser
comme ça voilà
je t'adore
tu es d'accord tu es d'accord avec
Guillaume Daniel oui en partie enfin moi
je pense que sur tout tu t'es trompé de
cible Gilles parce que et d'ailleurs le
silence est assourdissant c'est le
ministère de la Culture contre qui faut
être en colère que soit il ne savait pas
la proximité avec Dieudonnée
c'est un comité ça n'a rien à voir
Daniel avant
on voit
où quel spectacle et aller voir quelle
fête a été pigeon
toi et donc tu es susceptible de non non
non alors Delphine toi tu étais pas la
guerre oui mais je suis tout à fait
d'accord
parce que que tu sois d'accord nous on
est tous d'accord aussi
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec
Guillaume c'est vrai que bon voilà il
venait là pour parler de de quelque
chose c'est une fierté de recevoir la
Légion
une distinction voilà et
Gilles prendre quelque chose sorti de
son contexte et puis ensuite faire le
procès de l'invité comme souvent ça se
passe ici d'ailleurs sur le plateau les
invités doivent penser à deux fois avant
de venir parce que parce que ils ont une
chance sur deux de se faire défoncer en
fait elle est sympa
prendre un détail
forcément quand on va te poser la
question la vidéo aura une chance sur
deux que tu dis mais c'est impossible
c'est inadmissible et tout et tout et
donc
pardon alors elle était en train de
t'enterrer Delphine pardon alors moi je
soutiens à 2000 % Gilles Verdez merci
Gilles tu as été extrêmement courageuse
hier et je te félicite donc oui je
comprends ta colère parce qu'en fait le
problème de Francky Vincent rien à voir
avec son son son sa musique
et son flou en fait quand on lui pose la
question est-ce que vous condamnez
l'antisémitisme de Dieudonné il n'a pas
répondu il a dit je ne suis pas là pour
condamné non il a dit je ne suis pas là
pour condamner
je ne suis pas un juge je suis là il a
dit
il a dit je ne suis pas là
je ne comprends pas que tu sois pas
choqué
si vous êtes un peu oui dans un tribunal
vous êtes insupportable à tout juger
tout condamné qui disent et les mauvais
choix
quand on est antisémite
vous dites ça arrête quoi vous dites ça
pour vous faire bien voir mais il y a un
fossé entre vous sur les plateaux télé
qui dit ça et faire mousser pour
participer au tribunal médiatique mais
les gens chez eux les gens qui sont chez
eux qui regardent Dieudonné et qui
rigole ne sont pas antisémites les gens
qui sont chez eux et qui regardent un
match de la Coupe du Monde au Qatar ne
sont pas homophobes arrêtez c'est le
tribunal médiatique de merde vous faites
ça pour vous faire bien voir et pour
juger les gens et distribuer les bons et
les mauvais points bien sûr que si
personne ne pense comme vous mais pas du
tout on n'arrête pas un danger c'est
vous les dangers publics c'est qu'il y a
un mec qui vient pour parler de ses
chansons il ressort il accusé
d'antisémitisme à cause de vous demander
les les les blagues et les textes
antisémites de Dieudonné
imagine tu vas avoir un spectacle avec
un violeur ou un pédocrinel non je ne
condamne pas mais je n'avais pas je suis
désolé
et que tu trouves que l'homme et
détestable Céline par exemple c'est une
ordure absolue tu peux dire que tu aimes
l'ordre
des questions le débat pourquoi on s'est
intéressé à ça c'est que quand on a une
distinction c'est vrai que l'oeuvre mais
l'homme aussi c'est ça c'est à dire
voilà voilà
est-ce qu'on a le droit une fois dans sa
vie d'avoir serré la main de quelqu'un
d'avoir été au spectacle de quelqu'un
d'avoir écouté la musique
parce que
on a croisé le regard de cette personne
on est de fait antisémite non vous allez
crier vous vous créez plein
d'antisémites vous créez plein de
d'homophobe plein de racistes parce que
c'est des gens qui ont côtoyé ces
gens-là qui leur ont dit bonjour c'est
vous qui êtes dangereux
c'est toi qui en disant ça c'est toi qui
crée des antisémites je pense qu'on est
toujours là pour rester sur la question
sur Gilles moi je soutiens Gilles parce
qu'on est toujours en train de condamner
ici les choses quand quelqu'un ne veut
veut pas dire ok c'est un bonhomme il a
pas voulu dire il assume moi j'ai écouté
des sketchs de Dieudonné avant il m'a
fait beaucoup rire le cancer le pygmée
et le 11 septembre je rigole quand
j'écoute Dieudonné seulement maintenant
ce qui a fait Dieudonné quand il a des
propres antisémites je les condamne et
ici si on m'avait posé la question
j'aurais dit d'accord
je peux aller sur Youtube et regarder le
sketch des films et je vais avoir les
larmes sauf que il est parti en couille
à un moment donné alors justement
pourquoi il a pas dit ça pourquoi
parce que je suppose aussi pour
connaître un peu les gens des des
insulaires que ils sont de très forte
personnalité de vraisemblablement sa
famille et pendant des décennies ils ont
vécu dans l'esclavage je rappelle quand
même que il y a à peine un siècle tu te
tuer un noir aux États-Unis c'était pas
très grave tu vois parce que c'était un
noir donc ce mec tout d'un coup il se
retrouve en face de quelqu'un qui doit
obéir qu'il lui dit tu vas le dire ou tu
vas pas le dire et lui dit non je
n'obéis pas c'est ça qui l'a fait
Francky il a pas voulu obéir mais dans
son fort antérieur bien sûr que ce mec
il est ni antisémite Franqui et bien sûr
qu'il condamne les yeux il a pas voulu
comme on dit l'avouer c'est-à-dire
Gilles voulaient de lui dire à vous non
c'est parce que il avait une exigence
rien de ce que j'ai dit je le redirai
pareillement à Monsieur Franck et
Vincent ensuite Jean-Marie présuppose
que Francky Vincent regrette et n'a pas
voulu dire parce que m'excusez-moi moi
j'en suis pas là du tout il est allé
chez Dieudonné c'est pas c'est pas un
sketch ou rire à d'un sketch Guillaume
il est allé chez lui pour le bal de la
quenelle ensuite il dit que c'est son
idole donc pour moi excusez-moi mais
tant qu'il ne condamne pas ça moi je me
demande si au fond de lui il n'adhère
pas au test de Dieudonné c'est ça le
problème
c'est déjà plus correct de te demander
parce que là
attendez là vous me connaissez mal vous
me connaissez s'il était là je lui
redirai la même chose il n'est pas là je
vous le dis à vous si vous voulez si
vous cautionnez ce que Francky Vincent
pense ce que vous êtes responsable
n'a pas dit c'est pire que tout de pas
le dire oui oui mais c'est quand même
différent mais c'est pas bien ce que
vous faites Jean-Marie
l'antisémitisme vous adhérez à
l'antisémitisme c'est tout simple
Jean-Marie
c'est pas bien Jean-Marie c'est pas bien
j'ai dit je condamne
antisémite parce que moi je ne le suis
pas je peux très bien te le dire droit
dans les yeux lui il a eu un peu de mal
et du coup
exécuter c'est pour ça ma position j'ai
trouvé que c'était un peu à la cosaque
et c'est pour ça que j'ai ouvert ma
gueule que je ferme habituellement tout
le temps de négocie pas on ne négocie
pas avec l'antisémitisme le racisme ils
sont des délits donc à partir du moment
où il y a un soupçon soit la personne en
face je suis désolé c'est pas de la veux
soit elle se dégage de ça ou soit elle
reste que elle reste soupçonnée et là
moi je reste sur mes positions alors
Gilles on t'a aujourd'hui tu as une
journée difficile tu as même trouvé une
quenelle des milliers de messages
de quoi alors ça fait un peu peur je
vous le cache pas j'en ai parlé avec
Valérie tout à l'heure alors est-ce que
tu peux lui répondre maintenant
[Musique]
Jean-Marie là tu on va commencer vous
voulez bien serrer quand on commence par
ça parce que Jean-Marie là il commence
avec alors voilà il y a cette photo qui
a circulé bien sûr comme si je faisais
une quenelle exactement voilà alors je
vous le dis ça c'était dans il en pense
quoi ton frère absolument spécial
chroniqueur et si on a la séquence on va
voir qu'il est absolument pas
questionnaire on a la c'est quoi regarde
bien en moyenne en particulier des
autobus qui sont très souvent
à l'heure disponible et votre sœur elle
en pense quoi et ma sœur
[Musique]
ça fait partie vraiment d'une d'une
campagne assez violente qui a été menée
aujourd'hui avec des milliers de
messages qui qui c'est quoi les messages
qui me pose problème bah j'ai eu des
trucs
on prendra ton cadavre
j'espère que tes proches subiront les
conséquences de ce que tu dis on va te
retrouver viens pas aux Antilles sinon
tu es mort je vous en donne quelques-uns
qui sont odieux mais encore acceptables
ça a été d'une extrême violence et
moi ça me pose des questions sur l'état
de notre pays c'est vrai que ça m'a
beaucoup perturbé j'ai eu beaucoup de
soutien mais aussi des gens qui je le
trouve font des concessions à
l'antisémitisme mais ça c'est pas
acceptable Cyril il faut le rappeler on
ne peut pas accepter ça et Jean-Marie
vous avez vu la preuve
Jean-Marie vous avez vu l'image vous
avez vu l'image vous m'avez demandé de
m'expliquer moi je me suis expliqué
parce que c'était effectivement on vient
de le voir souligner les conditions bien
sûr c'est bien alors
quand vous avez dit que vous aviez des
messages un peu virulents
comme quoi on prend une image sortie
sans contexte qui n'a rien à voir on dit
lui l'antisémite c'est exactement ce que
tu as fait Francky Vincent hier
que c'est quelqu'un dont il est proche
peut-être qu'il a pas envie de le
lyncher publiquement il a dit qu'il
était contre l'antisémitisme qui
trouvait que c'était mal qu'est-ce que
vous voulez
retrouver les images il a dit que
c'était mal il n'a pas voulu le
condamner parce que peut-être qu'il a
compris condamner au sens juridique et
voilà il a pas dit l'antisémitisme
c'était bien de lui faites pas dire ce
qu'il n'a pas dit victime de pensée
Guillaume c'est grave ce que vous dites
là vous êtes vous avez affirmé que parce
que j'ai eu des messages extrêmement
violents je devrais changer d'avis mais
arrête de faire la victime mais lui même
pas répondre à cause de toi tu
pleurniche alors que lui il va lui dire
arrête Guillaume arrête je suis fier de
ce que je dis je répondais à Cyril qui
m'a dit qu'elle était beau message j'ai
hésité à abandonner le contenu de
certains je l'ai fait et Guillaume vous
pouvez pas dire que à cause de ces
messages on doit changer d'avis c'est
vous qui êtes en train de céder à
l'antisémitisme alors on va voir on va
voir
les spectateurs de la question oui à 11%
non voilà lien avec Dieudonné
comprenez-vous la colère de Gilles
Verdez hier face à l'écran qui Vincent
non à 80000 % les gens comprennent pas
donc ils sont pas tout à fait d'accord
avec le plateau vous voyez ils sont
d'accord avec Gilles avec Guillaume
Delphine et et Daniel on voit bien la
folie de Gilles qui vient de me dire
vous êtes en train de céder à
l'antisémitisme normalement c'est moi
personne ne pense comme Gilles Verdez
regardez les sondages c'est personne ne
mange pas n'importe quoi
je suis très fier de penser comme Gilles
Verdun qu'est-ce qui se passe avec rien
mais c'est c'est insupportable Gilles en
fait qui t'arrive ce qui va arriver à
Francky Vincent à cause de toi
c'est-à-dire que il se fait traiter
d'antisémites alors qu'il ne l'est pas
il va recevoir des insultes il va être
catégorisé parce que c'était quand même
devant des millions de personnes à cause
de toi on arrive la même chose à cause
d'un pauvre tweet et tu pleurniche donc
assume au moins une victime de ton mode
de pensée à toi qui est dégueulasse
est-ce que j'ai pleurniché oui bah oui
hier tu as dit je suis à deux doigts de
pleurer tu étais vraiment à deux doigts
de pleurer c'était sur le contenu le ski
disait pleurniche pas sur les messages
et je ne regrette rien Guillaume c'est
audio ce que vous dites franchement là
c'est pas bien de dire ça franchement
parce que là vous êtes en train de me
dire c'est des changer moi je ne
changerai pas c'est pas négociable de
changer là-dessus Guillaume c'est pas
négociable on ne peut pas transiger avec
l'antisémitisme et c'est ce que
il est en train de te dire en fait que
tu
quand tu tiens voilà un truc voilà une
photo qui passe un truc un extrait qui
passe sur les réseaux comme ça ça prend
tout de suite une ampleur incroyable et
que toi tu es un aussi un voilà tu peux
parfois être un catalyseur de ce genre
de chose voilà il te dit pour lui pour
lui pour Guillaume Francky Vincent a dit
qu'il n'était pas antisémite il a pas
condamné antisémitisme mais il a dit
qu'il n'était pas antisémite mais que
toi depuis que pour avec ce que tu as
fait hier pour le dans maintenant dans
l'opinion publique générale il est
antisémite c'est ça ce que tu veux dire
exactement c'est ça c'est qu'on va
aujourd'hui on va fouiller dans le passé
des gens pour essayer de sortir des
trucs de leur contexte pour les
condamner et les accusés de choses
qu'ils ne sont pas et c'est extrêmement
dangereux c'est toi qui est dangereux
Gilles c'est toi qui a créé ça pourquoi
cette photo elle est sortie pour te
montrer que toi-même tu dis des
conneries c'est tout c'est c'est
n'importe quoi franchement c'est
dangereux de faire ça encore une fois on
est en train de créer des en train de
créer des homophobes des gens qui n'ont
rien demandé qui qui condamne ça
évidemment et et et c'est dangereux
c'est tout voilà
sortie du contexte là c'est une
déformation c'est pas sorti du contexte
ce sont des faits il est allé chez
Dieudonné j'ai raconté des faits
purement et simplement il ne sait pas
dégagé dans l'antisémitisme et des
soupçons qui pèsent sur lui donc
Guillaume je ne regrette rien je pense
que c'est à Francky Vincent de regretter
ce qu'il a dit hier